we're asked to move the orange dot to
negative 0.6 on the number line so the
point the dot right now is at 0 and
let's see this is negative 2 this is
positive 2 so each of these big slashes
look like it's 1 so this would be
negative 1 negative 2 this right over
here would be negative 0.5 so we're
going to go a little bit more negative
than negative 0.5 that would be negative
0.6 we want to go another tenth and so
that looks right at about negative 0.6
let's do a couple more of these move the
orange dot to 1.9 on the number line so
it seems like we have the same scale as
in the previous example this gets us to
1 in fact this is 0.5 11.5 and 1.9 is
only going to be 1/10 less than 2 so
it's going to be let's see that's - so
1/10 less than that and I'm assuming
that it's locking us to the tenths and
it looks like it is so that looks pretty
close to 1.9 let's do one more of these
move the orange dot to 0.5 on the number
line
well that's once again we have the same
scale it's important to always check the
scale and this right over here is 1 so
0.5 would be halfway set a little small
mark right over there